well after
many years many hairstyles many pounds
up and down
and appearances as a guest a contributor
uh snow white
i guess co-host we're finally putting a
ring on it and making it official
congratulations but you walked onto the
set like the queen you are you were just
owning it
how good does it feel right now what
does this opportunity truly mean to you
i mean we've seen you in different
capacities on this set with this show
since 2013 but now it's official
okay what it represents is it being
official and i and i hope i hope
that um that it matters
um to little girls and little boys who
sound like me who look like me who maybe
immigrated from a different country and
found their home and their opportunity
here and so i'm grateful for the for the
platform i'm grateful for the viewership
um for the relevancy and the importance
and the influence the view has and i you
know and i
i've spent a lot of time in my life
talking about representation and how
much representation matters and so i
really feel that
that if i as much as i talk about it if
you get the chance to do it
you've got a responsibility to follow
through and so i that's what i hope
comes out of it without a doubt it will
you know
the viewers have just campaigned for you
to be a permanent fixture on this set
how much pool do you think the viewers
really did have
i don't know i don't know how much pool
the viewers have but i know that they
have a that they pull my heart strings
and i can tell you that i read them i
i'm so grateful for them viewers of the
view are incredibly loyal some of them
have been around for 25 years
they know loyal is joy they know uh
everything
uh that's going on in your life that's
why when you come to this place when you
come to this table you better be ready
to be authentic yeah and be yourself
because they they are they're on to you
if you're not and that's what they're
gonna that's what they've always gotten
for me and what i hope to continue
bringing to the table the ability to
speak truth to power to
call balls and strikes to call out
hypocrisy
the the ability to use this platform to
advance some some issues that are
important to me and i hope important to
to the country yeah and you represent a
side of the right a different faction i
guess you could say than that of alyssa
so how are you hoping
i'm not a trumper i've never been a
trumper i will never be a trumper i will
die never supporting trump but other
than that
i think we're clear on that not a
trumper got it got it
ever ever
uh but how are you hoping that your view
will shape political stances at the
table in the audience viewers honest to
goodness um look i i care a lot less
about political um
labels
than i do about values uh philosophy
things you believe in when you come to a
table like the view you better know who
you are and be ready to defend it
and i think there's a lot of dissension
within republicans there's a lot of
dissension within democrats uh but you
know at the end of the day we're all
americans since that we that's what we
have to remember
and so
for me the entire republican versus
democrat thing
is not something that drives my life
i want people who are honorable who
believe in the truth who don't divide
this country who don't spread propaganda
and conspiracy theories that's the kind
of people that i want to see in power
do you feel like you'll be sparring with
one co-host a little bit more than the
other potentially depends on the issue
yeah there's some things uh there are
some things that uh i agree with someone
there's some things that i disagree with
some on so i don't think so you know
we've always been
um willing to bring our differences to
the table that's what it's about yeah
right yeah uh and
it uh it depends on the issue fair
enough have you received any advice from
current co-host or past co-host in
regards to being
you know
a permanent co-host here at this table
look i think um you know whoopi goldberg
of course has such wisdom and she's so
generous in sharing it joey behar uh
gives advice uh offers guidance
sarah sarah haynes provides a
sunny sanity
and um and sunny sunny hosting is an
hermana she's a sister she's um she
provides solidarity and encouragement
wonderful
i think you're in great hands and you're
going to shine up there at that table
finally how many days do you think
you'll be here in new york versus miami
well at least two okay a day uh and then
it depends you know um
whoopee films
uh enjoy those things joy does joy goes
off and does things whoopi goes up and
does things sarah has the chase
everybody's got different
different things
[Music]
you